[Music]
in june 2023 we'll see the release of
the flash one of the most anticipated dc
movies in recent years similar to the
loki series and spider-man no way home
the first solo appearance of the
superhero will open up a multiverse so
far there is little information about
the plot of the movie so today in our
latest original you will not only learn
everything about the production of the
cast but also our theories about this
story of the flash
as mentioned at the beginning the movie
is the very first solo appearance of the
lightning fast dc superhero at least if
you leave aside the flash series which
now comprises 8 seasons unfortunately
there are no leaks on the plot or even
official information at the moment
because apart from the first trailer
from october 2021 those responsible are
still keeping a rather low profile what
is clear however is that the story told
in the movie will be strongly based on
the comic flashpoint which is why we
want to briefly introduce it to you the
flashpoint comics were published by dc
in 2011 and were penned by jeff jones
who has also worked on almost all of the
major dceu movies and series in recent
years either as a producer or writer the
comic marks a seminal break in the dc
canon as the new 52 begins after it and
does a reboot of almost all the
publishers comic series the comics plot
is extremely offbeat for example
superman is no longer with loose lane
but with wonder woman the justice league
also looks different than before because
in flashpoint it is no longer a state
association but just a loose gathering
of various superheroes barry allen aka
the flash wakes up in a completely
different world he no longer has any
superpowers and his family is also
completely mixed up his actually dead
mother is alive and is actually a living
father is dead to make matters worse his
nemesis captain colt is the celebrities
superhero of central city and the
justice league as we know it never
existed looking beyond central city
however the extent of the changes
wrought by the multiverse really becomes
clear as the world has gone completely
off the rails batman's real name is
thomas wayne soon bruce has been shot in
an alley and his wife mother has become
the joker the amazons have conquered the
united kingdom and the atlanteans led by
aquaman have submerged western europe
pretty messy isn't it barry allen thinks
so two and seeks advice from batman
where he realized that he is not in a
parallel dimension but an alternate
reality he blames the villain eobard
sonic a reverse flash for the chaos and
wants to put his stuff to him by
reconstructing the accident that gave
him his superpowers after an
unsuccessful attempt it actually works
and he quickly sets out to contain the
chaos that has arisen in the world
together with batman and cyborg he wants
to stop wonder woman and aquaman in
addition the trio finds a caged superman
who has never seen another person in his
life and is completely terrified slowly
but surely barry realizes that he must
stop eobard thon at all costs after some
superheroes join forces it comes to the
actual showdown between flash and
reverse flash which ultimately ends
victorious for the superhero during the
subsequent trip to the past to set
everything straight and save his mother
from death berry realized the existence
of three timelines dc vertigo and
wildstorm a mysterious figure reveals to
the flash that the world has been split
into three timelines to save it from the
danger of the villain dr manhattan he
should also look familiar to fans away
from the comics as the extremely
powerful villain first appeared in the
2009 movie watchman and was also
featured in the 2019 series of the same
name the three worlds eventually merge
and barry wakes up in his bed much like
he did at the beginning of the comics
hoping it will all be over now we know
the story of the flashpoint comics and
have a rough overview of what happened
but what exactly will actually be seen
in the movie that is much more difficult
to estimate we can at least assume that
the plots will be very similar after all
even flashpoint was originally intended
as the movie's title lead actor ezra
miller confirms that the movie is
extremely important for the dcu and
screenwriter christina hudson speaks of
the cinematic multiverse emerging from
his movie so the flash definitely has
the potential to be something like no
way home for the dceu no matter how much
of the comics will be adopted in the
movie we can look forward to an exciting
and given the actors also a nostalgic
blockbuster
fortunately the movie has long been
wrapped up because after filming started
in april 2021 it was already completed
in october in fact the flash looks back
on along and in places uncertain
production history back in 2014 ezra
miller was signed to play the flash and
the script was supposed to be written by
chris miller and phil lord in the
meantime the two eventually left the
project to work on solo and star wars
story which is why seth graeme smith was
supposed to take over directing and
riding didn't last either as he left the
project again in the spring of 2016 due
to creative differences he was followed
by the mandalorian director wreck family
eva who also threw in the towel after a
few months the production threatened
slowly but surely to become a disaster
and so warner brothers wanted to sign
either back to the future director
robert zemeckis or kick-ass director
matthew vaughn according to a report by
variety you can already guess that
didn't work out either another
unsuccessful station had the spider-man
homecoming writers john francis daly and
jonathan goldstein who were after all
responsible for over a year until march
2019. this was followed by a radical
reboot as lead actor as ramilla
encouraged a rewrite of the script and
realized it together with comic legend
grant morrison shortly thereafter birds
of prey writer christina hudson and it
director andy mosghetti were signed on
who were ultimately allowed to keep
their posts quite a turbulent story that
took place before the actual shooting in
the end however it seems that with
hudson and musgary two capable forces
were found
let's move on to the cast of the flash
which consists of far more well-known
people than just as formiva on the one
hand there's ben affleck as batman he
embodies his own version that fought
steppenwolf together with barry allen in
justice league the two characters are
also said to be more connected than you
might think as bruce wayne is a mentor
of sorts to barry allen another batman
will be embodied by michael keaton as in
batman returns and is also expected to
play a major role in the plot another
important character is super girl who
will be played by sasha kelly
unfortunately it is not known if
supergirl will be cara denver's lara
lane canned or some other version
barry's mother nora will be played by
maribel verdu and barry's father henry
will be played by ron livingston however
there are also some unconfirmed actors
who are said to be involved in the flash
for example jason momoa as aquaman and
gal gadot as wonder woman are said to be
involved that would make sense in light
of the flashpoint comics and is more
than likely in our opinion cyborg is
also expected to play a role and ray
fisher has already indicated his
willingness to play a role in the flash
in the past this situation is similar
with the zachary levios shazam however
it can be assumed that we will still
have to deal with one or the other
surprise guest will perhaps be teased in
a new trailer
even though the previous trailer from
october 2021 is only relatively short
it's worth taking a closer look we see a
cap arriving at wayne manor in the
trailer and we can recognize michael
keaton's batman quite well by his voice
he asks the flesh what the reason for
his fight to save the universe is
considering the plot in the comics we
suspect that the woman in the trailer is
barry's mother nora for whom he went
through the hardships of time travel in
the first place at the end we see a
group of three characters the flash
supergirl and a mysterious third person
this one visually looks a lot like the
flashback somehow ends up being
different from the main character since
the release of the trailer there have
been many speculations about this third
character some think of another flash
like jay garrick other ceo bird thon aka
reverse flash despite the comparatively
short duration of the trailer you can
already guess a few things and hopefully
we can look forward to a real trailer
with new material from the movie soon
and that's it for our latest original
what do you think which characters from
the dcu will appear in the flash and how
much will the film be influenced by the
flashpoint comics feel free to write us
in the comments see you next time
[Music]
you